hey all right everybody hey we got the
week off but we're here anyway I don't
know what's what what's happening I'm
not sure uh segment of the week off
whatever that's going to be dudy hinted
that it was holiday themed to some
degree okay right yeah I guess welcome
to the first official segment of the
week off will and Chad thanks for making
this historic moment possible but today
isn't a full episode just a special
segment for the holiday season I hope
you both had a great Thanksgiving I know
Adam Sandler did he had some very
special plans will get ready to embody
the S man as you read some of his latest
journal entries in a very special Adams
Applebee's this is Adam's Applebees
begin okay well as good a reason to uh
you know come back in and and and do
this for our wonderful pods out there
pal of dudy we hope uh you enjoy it's a
special segment for the for the thing of
the week post Thanksgiving Adam s and
here it is okay so this is a it's an
Adam it's it's Adam's Applebees as we're
used to okay hey hey hey hey buddy every
year the day after Thanksgiving I do a
special ritual pal I leave my family and
go to Dallas where they have the highest
concentration of Applebees per capital
and I go to five different Applebees
that are all about 20 minutes apart from
each other where I eat five Apple bees
meals in one day buddy I call it the
Applebees Black Friday Drive for5 p uh
because that that's who I am and and
that's where it's at and that's when
it's in and that that that's what it is
also buddy okay let's
go Jesus all right here's the first one
uh 2400 Aviation Drive Terminal D Dallas
Fort Worth Airport Dallas Texas hey hey
the best thing about my Applebee's Black
Friday Drive 4 5 is that the fun starts
even before the the plane touches down
into Big D buddy I take the same
non-stop La Dallas Morning flight every
year and every year the same Pilots
manned at 707 pal Captain Eddie and his
co- Captain
Steve a couple of good guys buddy I
shoot them a text for my seat and before
we take off they invite me up to the
cockpit
Yi oh the view from the cockpit is
magical pal and even more magical when
you're hi buddy Captain Eddie always has
plenty of sticky icky in the glove
compartment he's smoking weed with the
pilots of the plane yes and what Jesus
Christ I didn't know that cockpits have
remind me if I ever see Adam Sandler on
my plane to leave that plane I sticky
yiggy in the glove compartment and after
we reach 30,000 ft we like to fly just a
little higher pal I mean on marijuana
buddy we hot boox the cockpit pal we
have a good time buddy you know the
usual commercial airline cockpit
silliness I like to mess around and
touch all the knobs and the levers and
the plane rolling to and fro Eddie and
Stevie laughing their asses off while
they try to stop me pal inevitably we
end up slap fighting in a pile on the
floor buddy it's a fun time but the
plane jerks around like a [__]
and everyone in the cabin usually starts
screaming and carrying on so I get on
the PA system to cool them down down uh
this is your captain speaking pal uh we
seem to have hit a patch of rough Air
Buddy uh please keep your seat belts
fastened and make sure not to drop any
of your doobies pal I always get a few
laughs from the cabin whenever I clown
around on the PA glad everyone is having
a laugh buddy anyway immediately upon
Landing I take some funny picks with
Eddie and Stevie in the cockpit the
flight attendant gets some shots of us
blowing pot smoke in each other's faces
and pretending to punch punch one
another into
penises silly stuff then I head straight
to the Applebees inside Dallas Fort
Worth International and it's a great one
pal even though I got the munchies from
all of that Mary Jane I got to paste
myself buddy this is only my first
Applebees of the Day pal so I got only
got three orders of chicken tenders from
the kids menu buddy it's less chicken
tenders because it's from the kids menu
and I ate them all pal time to hop in
the cab and con continue my adventure
buddy all right so he's that's pretty
good he's on his way I did not know that
there there are Applebees and airports
hell yeah dude mhm I know that exact
Applebees I think it's in the American
Airlines terminal in DFW yeah you be in
a Dallas guy yourself I've been to that
airport I don't know a lot many many
times but yeah I've probably been to
some of these
Apple guess as well Applebees 3565
frankfur Road Road Dallas Texas
75287 hey hey hey every Applebees in the
greatest Greater Dallas area is a winner
but this one might take the cake buddy
comfy Booth courtious staff and a fryer
hotter than Troy
Aman what I head to the well he's the
the the former uh the quarterback of the
Dallas Cowboys 20 years ago yeah but
he's he's a beautiful man I head to the
little boys room to [__] out my
breakfast tenders and return to see my
table to my table to see that my server
has brought me a complimentary clubhous
Grill sandwich oh I get it pal I'm a
regular and it's the day after
Thanksgiving and the clubhouse is the
only item at Applebees with turkey in it
now there's a lesser known fact about
this handman I hate turkey buddy gabble
gabble gabble gabble [__]
up I can't even look at that sandwich
pal m is that true though doesn't he
have a whole song about Thanksgiving or
turkey or something like that oh yeah
that turkey ly D turkey turkey do he
hates it now I get I don't yeah well you
know I don't changed man none of this
what yes any at any rate I can't even
look at that sandwich pal so I
aggressively swipe it off my table and
Order up the chicken tender splatter
pushes it onto the floor and a crispy
chicken tender salad buddy and guess
what I hear you doll
pal after my server took my order she
moved to clean up the clubhouse grill
off the floor I tell her to leave it
there that I have a friend coming who
would love nothing more than to eat that
sandwich off of the grease stained
mildewy carpet she was a little confused
but she obliged buddy my friend that's
right you guessed it Dallas's favorite
son and my good pal Vanilla
Ice wow I guess he's a Dallas guy they
are friends in real life oh yeah they're
always in he's always in s a Dallas guy
he went to my rival High School really
RL Turner oh interesting okay there you
go remember uh no sooner had she moved
off to put my order in that Rob showed
up uh that's Vanilla Ice's real name pal
hey Vanilla Ice eat that sandwich off
the floor you stupid [__] I said oh my
God as he walked towards me smiling we
had a good laugh buddy ice is a great
guy pal been in a bunch of my movies
buddy going to put him in some more of
my movies too pal I paid the bill
leaving a nice tip for my server felt
bad about the sandwich thing but it had
to be done buddy the look on Vanilla
Ice's face was worth it pal I love
pranks buddy yeah we know that about him
and it was time to jump in Ice's car and
head off to the next Applebee's pal
rolling in his 5.0 with the rag top down
so his hair can blow that's from this
song Ice Ice Baby bu so now vanill ice
is going with him to the next location
to the next location which is Applebee
6464 East Northwest Highway Dallas Texas
when vanilla I and I pulled up we were
met with an incredible sight buddy one
that I've never seen before pal and
Applebee's Black Friday sale
buddy there was a line around the block
what are they what are they
selling I don't know flat screen TV
[__] wall get a 72 in TV get your
Apple TV there was a line around the
block people waiting to get in on the
savings chicken one ton tacos Brew Pub
loaded waffle fries Bourbon Street
mushroom swiss burgers all day long all
their bargain prices pal all right so
Rob and I got in line and hobnobbed with
our fellow Applebees faithful we had a
great time buddy it was a beautiful
experience being around that many
Applebee's fans uh
everybody sharing stories of how many
chickens they put away in one sitting
all the werewolves we've seen at
applebe other people I guess at least
that one time he saw a werewolf those
people saw saw yeah they uh the crazy
huge shits we've all plugged toilets
with it was a lot of fun pal pretty soon
though we realized that in order to keep
the Applebee's Black Friday drive45
going and still make my flight back to
LA we to hurry things up
buddy
okay and Vanilla Ice had a plan pal he
stood out in front of the crowd and
shouted all right stop collaborate and
listen my buddy Adam has to eat
chicken if I was in an apple and saw
that unfold I I don't know what I would
do it would be one of the greatest
moments of my life he went on to say
that if we all just give our order to
the first person in line then that guy
could make one huge order for all of us
that way we would all get our food at
the same time and continue our impromptu
Applebees convention in the parking lot
it was a great idea buddy everybody had
the or gave the orders to the first guy
and we had our food in around 20 minutes
pal
after that's what takes the time it's
the ordering it's not the the
preparation of the food no no no no it's
it's smart I like this idea good plan
from Vanilla Ice yeah uh after everyone
finished their food I told the whole
group that I'm putting every last one of
them in my next movie it's about a guy
who meets a woman while shopping on
Black Friday and falls in love with her
and ends up buying a half off diamond
ring at the mall and proposes to her in
the food court the Applebees crowd plays
a mob of Shoppers that trampoline each
other to death in the first scene
buddy it's going to be it's going to be
a good movie pal it's a good opening to
a ROM c a [__] mob of people
trampling each other to death all right
here's the it's good couple more of
these I hope you guys are um enjoying
would you would you would you would you
have for Thanksgiving you eat food ate
some food dude yeah man have some food
on Thanksgiving Applebees 34 26 West
Illinois Avenue Dallas Texas this
Applebee's location is fantastic every
time I dine here but not on this day
Vanilla Ice and I had ordered a couple
chicken tenders platters and our server
informed us that they do chicken tenders
a little differently there buddy turns
out local billionaire investor and owner
of the Dallas Mavericks Mark Cuban had
been buying up Dallas area Applebees and
serving lab grown Meats in all of them
oh unbeknownst yeah I guess this he was
just doing this without telling anyone
yeah I you can't do that right it's a
franchise it's yeah I think you probably
would have to disclose if you're it's
like well no cuz you don't have to
disclose if you're doing GMO [__] maybe
you wouldn't have to I don't know yeah
but I don't you can't just be like hey
I'm starting a Burger King and here's
mashed potato sandwiches you ever had a
mashed potato
sandwich probably I mean it's a Midwest
thing I guess there was a point in
college where all I was eating was uh
bagels and mashed
potatoes turns out local billionaire
investor and owner of the Dallas
Mavericks Mark Cuban has been buying up
Dallas area Applebees and serving lab
grown Meats in all of them some crack
pop business scheme he bought into on
that stupid Shark Tank TV show he does
wait somebody came in and pitched
Applebee's or pitch lab grown Meats what
what was the Shark Tank picture it
soundss like somebody came in and said
hey you know Applebees what if we make
lab grown Meats I'm a scientist I got
some weird Meats gr my instarting pinch
is you buy every Applebees I'll make lab
grown meat for them yeah yeah yeah I got
a weird I got I got some I got some a
fridge in my garage with some weird
Petry dishes in it I want to walk into
shark tang and be like here's my pitch
Apple bees do I have your investment no
I meant the the computer company oh okay
yeah that'd be smart too yeah but if you
add a bees to it then you know what that
spells
yeah yeah uh Vanilla Ice and I weren't
having it pal we demanded to speak with
Mark Cuban
immediately our server told us he wasn't
there as he was vacationing on a yacht
in Monaco [__]
buddy we angrily stomped into the
kitchen and turned it upside down
throwing pots and pans all over the
place smearing ranch dressing on the
walls Vanilla Ice even pissed in a big
bowl a flower pal that's [__]
disgusting why why would he do it
they're pissed they're angry yeah
finally
Mark finally Mark Cuban emerged from a
cupboard we actually had a productive
conversation with him and he convinced
us to try the test tube chicken tenders
buddy they tasted exactly like
Applebee's traditional chicken tenders
and we ate them all pal couldn't tell
the difference I guess they couldn't
tell the difference interesting very
interesting
I as I've said before here on dudy give
me the lab meat if it tastes good I'll
I'll eat the [__] [__] I'll be a
little worried about it and uh I don't
think it's a good idea overall but I'm
just being honest I won't be able to uh
there's no way I not be able I wouldn't
be able to turn down that meat how about
you no I don't like meat but think of it
like this dude all meat is essentially
lab grown meat the lab is called planet
earth oh gee okay okay yeah okay
uh then something super [__] up
happened
buddy now something [__] up happened
we got vanilla I pissing in a [__]
bowl of flour now it's going to get
[__] up okay ice had a bad allergic
reaction and you'll guessed it he turned
into a werewolf
[Applause]
pal ran off into the streets of Dallas
never to be seen or heard from again
buddy I'm going to miss my pal Vanilla
Ice pal [__] Mar
Cuban all right here's the last one
Applebees 2251 Grape Vine Mills Circle
grape vine Texas what I've been to that
one really is prob like 5 minutes from
uh my sister's house really yeah oh good
stuff I definitely I've eaten that one
multiple times I love it I love it Mark
Cuban felt bad about turning Vanilla Ice
into a werewolf so he agreed to drop me
off at my next and final Applebees Black
Friday Drive 4 five location one that he
hadn't infected with his stupid mad his
stupid mad scientist meat buddy I ripped
a huge fart before stepping out of his
car
[Music]
pal uh that's what I think of your
Unholy Frankenstein meat I shouted
before slamming the door Mark cubin
inhaled my ass G deeply and gave me the
finger that dude sure is Goofy buddy
that's a good move I like that if if
someone farts in your car
just sniff it up next time I fart in
your car what do you think try it don't
Oren don't fart in the car what a
surprise sitting in a big comfy Booth
near the front where Captain Eddie and
co- Captain Stevie and holy crap they
were high pal I slid into the booth and
took a dank hit from their
bong shaped like an airplane buddy just
openly smoking weed out of a bong in
Dallas Texas
Applebee's immediate jail that's what it
says yeah immediate jail yeah they're
they're Pilots Chad oh yeah sorry uh uh
uh bong shaped like an airplane buddy
stunning glass work pal this things cost
at least 300 bucks buddy that's accurate
a plain shaped bong probably run you
three 400 bucks sure we tore into
neighborhood beef nachos Brew Pub
pretzels and beer cheese dip and lots
and lots and lots and lots and lots of
chicken tenders hey hey hey hey hey you
guessed it we ate them all pal of course
Stevie was so ripped he started drinking
side sauces like they were shots honey
barbecue garlic parmesan classic Buffalo
extra hot buffalo Stevie's a Madman
buddy yeah just then Vanilla Ice
werewolf smashed through a
window and landed on a table of where a
family of five were enjoying a nice
dinner scared the living [__] out of
them pal he backed the family into a
corner his fangs dripping with blood uh
uh with the blood of who knows what or
who he toore tore up while rampaging
through Dallas the youngest of the
family a fat little boy in a Dallas
Maverick shirt bravely stood for Ward
and threw a chicken tender at Vanilla
Ice werewolf who swallowed it whole and
then a miracle happened buddy oh
consuming the chicken tender turned
Vanilla Ice werewolf back into Vanilla
Ice oh and it's a good thing too because
the fat little boy had his gun drawn and
pointed at Rob as he transformed back
into his former self pal everyone in
Texas is packing buddy that's true
that's true that's like the only
accurate part of all of this I feel like
is that there was a 10-year-old kid with
a [__] loaded weapon and an
Applebees after that me Vanilla Ice
Eddie and Stevie smoked a bunch of weed
with the with the fat little boy and his
family oh Jesus we took some fun
pictures too pretending to punch each
other in the penis pretending the pl
bong was a penis and pointing and
laughing at Vanilla Ice's penis which
was exposed because turning a well into
a
wolf tore his clothes off just like in
the movies pal hey hey hey hey speaking
of movies you got to go see my new movie
when it comes out buddy it's called
Applebees Black Friday Drive 4 five and
it's based on a true story
pal pretty good pretty there's some
interesting [__] in there I like the um
the business plan of buying up all the
Applebees and serving lab grown meat
unbeknownst to people oh man I pleasa we
there needs to be uh some vanilla ice
werewolf I just Vanilla Ice werewolf I
think is uh someone's leaving something
on the table I think Robert vanwinkle uh
real name of Ice Ice uh that dude
supposedly started like a uh some kind
of real estate thing around Dallas like
a house flipping thing and it's just
[__] raking in cash well there there
you have it uh light up the Chumps like
a candle right what does he say anyway
it's been a while chump like a candle
light up the stage and wax a chump like
candle light up the stage like a
candle like
Ace speakers at Boom the CHP like a
candle chump like a candle killing your
bra thank you to everyone for joining us
for the first ever segment of the week
off I hope you all had a fantastic
Thanksgiving and we'll see you next week
with a full episode until then call me
dud
Z if you like dud what you
please tell a friend and
revie if you like d what you
do please tell a friend
and if you like
d pleas tell then